but what we're experiencing in our own
Matrix of our mind is a reflection of
ourselves this is why when we change
certain aspects of ourselves or we see
ourselves more fully everything seems to
transform because we're just becoming
accepting and aware in our observation
the same thing goes for quantum physics
it all plays into the same concept of
what Consciousness is and why does it
even need to experience itself it's this
substance that makes up all things that
lives within every animal every tree
within the water every single thing is
alive and it's operating as one with
this Cosmic mind it really needs to
observe itself it needs to learn what is
the point of existence what is the
beautiful Harmony of coexistence what
does it mean to love what does it mean
to go into the experience of completely
being as one with everything else and
that beautiful experience of Oneness is
what we can experience when we detach
from separateness of I am my own ego and
everything else is somehow a separate
construct if you are Consciousness then
we are just the same thing that everyone
else is made of